the director general of the world health
organization says the findings of a new
report about global covid 19 deaths are
sobering it estimates roughly 15 million
people died directly or indirectly from
covet 19 in 2020 and 2021. that's more
than double the official global death
toll of 6 million the who said the
number of covet 19 related deaths ranges
from 13.3 million to 16.6 million
these figures include indirect deaths
such as those caused by ripple effects
in the health care system
globally we estimate 14.9
million existed associated with the
kogan 19 pandemic
by 31 december
of 2021
so this estimate ranges from 13.3
million to 16.6 million
there were
5.4 million
imported covet 19 debts to who over this
period
so this excess estimate represents
nine and a half million more deaths
or 2.75 times
more deaths than reported
data is indeed the lifeblood of public
health
covid has illuminated a staggering toll
already that we have seen 14.9 million
excess deaths but it has also
illuminated a staggering data gaps in
countries too much is unknown and there
is too much delays in getting life and
death information